president from toaster rally and the
media are very very upset about it a new
poll shows Republicans don't actually
mind Russian election interference and a
federal judge tries to ban 3d gun
printing we'll talk about all of it i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
so many things to get to today I just
have to you know pay tribute to the fact
that the daily wire is a company
celebrating our third anniversary
yesterday so that's pretty exciting
stuff no one in the audience actually
cares but I care so that means you care
now well now that you know that little
facts I'm gonna teach you something else
okay if you need stamps there's no
reason you ought to go to the post
office it doesn't matter how much you
love the post office means you're gonna
spend gas money and you have to go to
the post office and wait in line
listen post office is great but what is
better is being at your desk printing
out the stamps that you need on to your
envelope or on to a sticker or sticking
into the envelope you're ready to go
it's just great that's what Samsung does
for you with stamps calm you can access
all the amazing services of the post
office directly from your desk 24/7 when
it's convenient for you you can buy and
print official US postage for any letter
any package using your own computer and
printer the mail carrier just picks it
up you click print mail you're done we
here use stamps calm at the office at
the Daily wire offices our three-year
old offices we use it at my at my house
that we we have a scale that was given
to us by stamps calm it allows us to
actually use exact postage every single
time and right now you too can get all
of these services use Shapiro for this
special offer fifty five bucks a free
postage a digital scale and a four week
trial all you have to do is go to stamps
calm and before you do anything else you
click on the radio microphone at the top
of the homepage and you type in Shapiro
again go to stamps comm a radio
microphone top the home page type in
Shapiro you have 55 bucks free postage
digital scale in a four week trial
stamps compro moco cheap hero to let
them know that we sent you terrific
service alrighty so president Trump did
another one of his patented rallies last
night and it got pretty rowdy because
President Trump's rallies are always
rowdy now what's weird to me is that the
media are so deeply concerned over this
if they were so deeply concerned over
president Trump's rallies maybe they
should have stopped covering them
soup-to-nuts when he was doing them in
the middle of the election cycle but
Trump loves these things he's a guy who
plays to the crowd if you've ever seen
president from speak in person this is
somebody who really is a performer and
as somebody who like I used to perform
regularly not just in terms of you know
doing my speaking in front of an
audience but I used to actually perform
I was a classical violinist used to
perform in front of audiences and you
know when the audience's into it when
the audience isn't into a President
Trump he's really good at this he is a
performer and so he knows when the
audience is into it when they're not and
so he does these rallies they are very
rowdy and they're very excited
and the media went nuts yesterday they
were very very upset about this and I'm
at a loss to explain quite why brian
schatz
who is a senator from Nevada he tweeted
out we have no equivalent to the Dark
Carnival that is a Trump rally
this is not a thing on the left we just
argue about health care and climate and
sometimes relitigate 2016 but we are not
actually out of our minds
it's a Dark Carnival over at the Trump
rally I just like to point out to Brian
Schatz that history did not start
yesterday there was this weird syndrome
on the left that suddenly all history
began with Donald Trump so yesterday we
talked about LeBron James saying that
Trump has politicized sports ignoring
the fact that sports has been
politicized for years and years and
years and years and that the
politicization of our culture and our
sports that's one of the reasons why
Trump has been so successful because
Trump is a counterpunch to all of that
politicization well the same thing is
true when it comes to the quote unquote
Dark Carnival of Trump rallies hey I'm
old enough to remember in 2011 after
Paul Wellstone who is a senator in from
Minnesota after he died in a plane crash
I'm old enough to remember when
Democrats led in actual rally at Paul
wellstones funeral I mean it's like this
is a thing that actually happened
[Applause]
[Music]
this election
will you stand up and keep fighting for
social and economic justice say yes
and as dr. over 2002 that was it a
funeral for Paul Wellstone it was a
funeral memorial for Paul Wellstone but
don't worry
only trump has been involved in the Dark
Carnival of rallies again those all the
way back in 2002 they're a bunch of
Republicans sitting in the audience who
just went there to pay tribute at the
memorial and I remember all these people
getting up there and shouting about how
Republicans were the worst thing ever at
this at this event in memoriam for a
senator who died in a plane crash and of
course we saw this happen at in Tucson
after the Gabby Giffords shooting
you remember that President Obama
traveled down to Tucson where he did a
full-on anti-gun rally like a pep rally
against guns in which he and everybody
else tore into the gun culture in the
United States and prompted actual
mainstream media discussions as to
whether this was a memorial service for
those who had died in the Tucson
shooting or whether it in fact wasn't a
pep rally here's you know folks in the
mainstream media talking about at the
time is back in 2011 chip let me ask you
was what was the White House expecting
and when they had the speech in their
hands walked into the venue did they
know it was going to have this mix of
you know memorial and pep rally I think
they probably figured it out when the
president walked in and there was a
scream that went up like I've never
heard before it really was extraordinary
because I think like Roger I and Robert
Gibbs said today he - were expecting a
much more solemn occasion okay and the
crowd was going nuts I remember this it
was it was a big story at the timing
members of the mainstream media we're
talking about whether this was
appropriate in 2011 Torrey it's the Dark
Carnival of trumpism there's been no
other Dark Carnival you know when I need
600 police officers to escort me into
Berkeley that's not a Dark Carnival in
any way when an Tifa is breaking apart
actual Trump rallies when people are
showing up and punching people in Trump
hats when Maxine Waters an actual
sitting Congress person is encouraging
people to be confronted in parking lots
of gas stations that's not anything dark
that's just how Democrats do politics
you know they're cordial and they're
civil that's just that's how they are
but these Republicans that really talk
Occupy Wall Street I'm old enough to
remember when people were occupying
parts and rape was actually happening at
occasional events of Occupy and I'm old
enough to remember at the Trump
inauguration when people from Antigua
where we're throwing gas canisters and
breaking cars but don't worry nothing
dark has ever happened in Paulo
up till now it's one of the great
irritants to me is when people are just
ignorant of history not just ignorant of
history but willfully blind to stuff
that happened legitimately about five
minutes ago in the great timeline of
American politics when you see this
yesterday from the media as well so Jim
Acosta was at this Trump rally yesterday
and there are a bunch of people who were
mocking Jim Acosta and mocking CNN he
was very upset about it
[Music]
[Applause]
and if you can't see this there are
people who are flipping off Jim Acosta
flipping off CNN having a good time and
of booing CNN and Jim Acosta then
tweeted out just a sample of the sad
scene we faced at the Trump rally in
Tampa I'm very worried that the
hostility whipped up by Trump and some
in conservative media will result in
somebody getting hurt
we should not treat our fellow Americans
this way the press is not the enemy I
sort of agree with the idea that we
shouldn't treat our fellow Americans
this way but I do have a question which
is the same media who apparently didn't
care at all when Trump supporters were
legitimately being beaten up outside
rallies in San Jose who didn't care when
a Trump rally was getting shut down by
protesters in Chicago who didn't who
barely covered for like a week the
actual shooting of Congress people of
Republican Congress people at a softball
game in Northern Virginia who don't care
when Charles Murray is run off campus at
physical risk and a leftist professor
actually ends up concussed maybe who
under cover all of this stuff but then
when it's the media then it's the end of
the world and specifically when it's the
left media it's the end of the world
when when the Family Research Council is
shot up by a guy who read the Southern
Poverty Leadership Council they're their
hate map and decided to target the the
FRC that's not a huge story when the
media decide what to cover and what not
to cover and then the only thing they
seem to care about covering is
themselves you can't be all that
surprised when people are upset now
that's not an excuse for treating people
badly I don't think it's an excuse for
standing there and shouting at Jim
Acosta and first of all I think you're
helping Jim Acosta when you do this it
allows Jim Acosta to play victim it
allows Jim Acosta to pretend that he is
some sort of Braveheart character
standing out there amidst the slings and
arrows it allows Jim Acosta to posture
which is his favorite thing to do Jim
Acosta loves Jim Acosta so much that I
assume when you go to his apartment Jim
Acosta actually has life-size cutouts of
Jim Acosta just all-around right there's
like one standing at the fridge and then
there's one at the bathroom holding his
razor for him
Jim Acosta loves him some Jim Acosta you
are actually benefiting Jim Acosta when
you do this sort of thing but let's
let's be real about this media
pretending that this is something new in
American politics and that they have not
contributed to this climate is just
insane remember CNN held a full-scale
gun-control rally
complete with shaming rituals directed
at the NRA and Marco Rubio just a few
months ago after the power
shootings we talked about it at the time
and included a reporter who I think is
very often good Jake Tapper right Jake
was who was doing the interviews and it
turned into this pathetic ritual where a
bunch of people would get up and and
suggest that Marco Rubio was equivalent
to a mass shooter in a in a public high
school and we're supposed to believe now
that everything that's happening is new
the demonization in politics is new the
mistreatment of media members is new
that rallying at inappropriate events is
new first of all this was a trump rally
okay like what did you expect Trump's
rallies have been like this from the
very beginning they've always been rowdy
nothing has changed I've been critical
of the rowdiness of some of trumps
rallies for a very long time but the the
media's pretend ignorance about all of
this is really kind of going and that's
what people are reacting to and then
people wonder Oh what people in media
why do they why do they dislike us so
much we're just scare covering the facts
we're just here reporting why do they
dislike us so much well maybe it's
because you pose yourselves as the
conscience of America versus the rest of
America
nobody likes a schoolmarm nobody likes a
nanny and and and nobody likes an
insulting me any more than anything else
mark Caputo is a reporter at Politico he
actually tweeted this out in response to
Jim Acosta if you put everyone's mouth
together in this video you'd get a full
set of teeth yes I'm sure that is going
to really ramp down the rhetoric here
I'm sure that is really going to make
sure that everybody treats each other
with a certain level of civility and
decency that we have not yet found in
American politics and there all these
polls showing people don't trust the
media one of the reasons people don't
trust the media is because the people
believe that the media are self-serving
institution a lot of Trump supporters
believe the President Trump is fighting
for them one of the reasons they believe
the President Trump is fighting for them
and not for himself is because he
expresses sympathy for a lot of these
folks he doesn't call them bitter
clingers he doesn't suggest they're a
bunch of losers he'll say things like we
are the elites he expresses the
frustration of a lot of people in the
middle of the country particularly who
have felt culturally dispossessed by the
elites on the coast by the elitists I
should say on the coast for a very long
time
Trump expresses that particularly well
because Trump as a human being has a
certain level of insecurity that drives
him to feel like he's a guy outside the
party constantly he's had this for
decades and that resonates well with a
lot of people who felt like they had
been forcibly expelled from the party by
the cultural arbiters of decent
see by the folks like Jim Acosta and so
when Trump rallies those folks there's a
certain level of warmth to him but
there's not that same level of warmth to
the media the media who treat themselves
as a sort of cased apart they are sort
of cleek they're their clique of people
who are special and beyond you there are
geniuses arbiters of what is good and
bad in the United States as opposed to
just fat tellers and truth tellers in
just a second I want to talk a little
bit more about that and the proof of
that first I want to talk to you about
this fantastic new podcast okay so I
loved the movie Jaws I think jaws is one
of the best movies ever made I'm an
addict to this movie actually I used to
watch it when I was on the treadmill
jaws great great movie well now if you
are curious about the behind the scenes
and drawers there's a fantastic new
podcast out it's called inside jaws it
is written and hosted by Mark Ramsey the
man behind inside cycle and inside the
Exorcist inside jaws takes on an
immersive journey through the making of
1975's pulse-pounding hit film jaws the
first ever summer blockbuster you'll
follow one of the prolific filmmakers in
history Steven Spielberg from the making
of his first eight-millimeter Western
his young Boy Scout to the rocky
production and groundbreaking release of
a movie that changed the film industry
forever and instills a healthy fear of
the water and millions of people around
the world to this day it really is an
awesome film and one of the great things
about draws is that you barely see the
shark when you do see the shark it's
great but you barely see it the whole
time it really is the model for how a
horror film should be made jaws again
Robert Shaw's performance and try one of
my favorite performances ever it's just
terrific and Roy Scheider go check out
all of the inside scoop all you have to
do to hear the first two episodes right
now is subscribe to inside jaws on an
apple podcast or by heading over to
wondering m / inside jaws or you can
listen the first four episodes ad-free
by signing up for one during plus at one
recom slash plus that's wo n de ry comm
/ plus-1 dree comm / + go subscribe to
inside jaws today it's just fantastic if
you love that inside Hollywood stuff
it's really really good and the movie of
course is great so go check it out it's
again called the inside drawers and you
can subscribe it laundry FM / inside
drawers ok so you know the media
treating themselves as a sort of special
group of people is one of the great
eared since I think to the American
people you see it every time there's
talk about First Amendment rights by the
media now I am almost a First Amendment
absolutist I'm about as close to a First
Amendment absolutist as you can get I've
gotten more libertarian on the First
Amendment Oh
over the course of my career just
because I fear the government
intervention in the First Amendment
sphere which we'll talk about in just a
little while there's a new case in which
the government looks to be cracking down
on the First Amendment in order to crack
down on the Second Amendment but the
media treat the First Amendment as
though it is a special preserve of
members of the media so when there's an
attempt to shut down people from
speaking at public universities then the
media treat it as though this is an
actual debate we ought to be having but
when there are members of the media who
are restricted from asking a question to
the President of the United States it's
the end of the world they are not
principled in their actual pursuit of
First Amendment rights the same media
that will that will champion the idea
that there should be restrictions on
quote/unquote hate speech will tell you
about how the media are a special
preserve of people and the freedom of
the press is our key freedom well the
freedom of the press was not a the idea
by some on the left is that you have to
be an accredited journalists to really
experience freedom of the press that's
not what freedom of the press meant the
same thing is true when it comes to
these sort of violent nasty rhetoric
we've been seeing in our politics the
media don't seem to mind so much when
it's targeted gun gun control opponents
when it's targeted at Second Amendment
advocates when it's targeted at social
conservatives when it's targeted at
religious bakers then they don't care so
much when there's all this ire and anger
and ginning up of outrage directed at
the people they don't like but as soon
as it's directed at the media themselves
then all of a sudden they get very very
touchy about this stuff very very
quickly then they say oh well now now I
feel like we're on the verge of a civil
war
now remember Jim Acosta is tweeting this
stuff out well the same media was
downplaying just a few weeks ago when a
Fox News reporter said that she couldn't
even report from the steps of the
Supreme Court because she was fearful of
the reaction of a bunch of lefties to
the nomination of Brett Kavanaugh so she
wouldn't go out there and report because
she felt like she was being threatened
the media said well you know that's
that's just I mean we were out there and
it was fine we were out there there was
no problem but when a CNN reporter gets
tossed out of the briefing room wrongly
in my opinion by the White House then
all of a sudden it's why aren't Fox News
do I learn two people on the right
defending us people on the right should
defend you and you know what you should
do you should defend the First Amendment
you should actually defend the civility
in the political process the same people
MSNBC will host Maxine Waters every
night of the week without actually
pressing her on whether it is
appropriate to tell people to accost
people in public places they the media
will champion folks who yell at
Christian Nielsen the Secretary of
Homeland
in a restaurant they will say this is
all good but then as soon as there are
some people who yell at you Mikasa at a
rally then it's the end of the world and
we're supposed to pretend that this is
something new in history started just
now like it we just figured out that
history just started it's it's really
irritating to a lot of folks and I think
that's the reason why you are seeing so
much ire I'm part of folks on the right
now I will say that I think that all of
this needs to calm down on on every side
there's been a lot of talk in the last
couple of years three years about an
upcoming civil war in the United States
and about the idea that we are going to
break out into fighting I wrote a
dystopian novel about the possibility of
civil war coming to the United States
the whole point of the dystopian novel
is that it is about five steps removed
from reality we are not there yet
right we are there are indicators that
conflict is on the way but the idea that
there's going to be some great armed
conflict or that we are in the middle of
the second civil war right now is just
absurd if you just walk around the
United States the idea that people are
going to be shooting each other in the
next couple of years is insane you could
not say the same thing in the lead-up to
the first civil war lead-up to the first
civil war you actually had a pre Civil
War in Kansas in 1856 it was called
bleeding Kansas where slaveholders and
and advocates for slavery and Free
Staters who were actually going at it
and shooting each other and murdering
each other in relatively significant
numbers in the state of Kansas they
actually had John Brown going down to
Harpers Ferry and trying to lead a slave
revolt and almost a dozen people being
shot right you actually had this sort of
stuff happening on a fairly regular
basis and there was open talk about the
possibility of a civil war leading up to
the Civil War it's very difficult to
look at today's United States and figure
that all the hemp smokers in San
Francisco are going to be at war with
the gun owners in Texas in the next few
years yet I think that both sides now
have an interest in ramping up the
rhetoric of civil war so on the Left you
have an interest in suggesting that
fascism is on the way and that we are
all going to be put under the tyrannical
boot of the Trump administration and on
the right you have an interest in
suggesting that the resistance the
so-called resistance of the left is
going to lead to the out to the
outgrowth of a civil war now I will
admit that when you are in the political
sphere and you're watching this stuff
every day it's very easy to be drawn
into this sort of rhetoric I don't think
I've been immune to it over the course
of my career it's easy to get alarmist
when you are immersed in politics
single day and then you turn off Twitter
and you go out into the world and you
realize nobody's actually ready to shoot
each other and the number of people who
are actually ready to clock each other
it's very very low which is why when
things have come to blows
very often the government backs down the
the case in point being for example the
Bundy ranch scenario where a cliven
Bundy and his sons essentially told the
the federal government to stand down and
some of them were arrested and then
there's some jury nullification and
nobody actually went to jail right when
when when the possibility of actual
violence is in the offing it seems like
there has been a generalized move to
back off of that as opposed to
exacerbating that and the problem with
the civil war rhetoric is that what it
actually does it justifies any sort of
behavior from any side so Victor Davis
Hanson who's a terrific writer Rebecca
Davis Hanson has written some of my
favorite books particularly on the
history of warfare he has a piece over a
National Review with which I
significantly disagree okay and it's
called the origins of our second civil
war and he writes how when and why has
the United States now arrived at the
brink of a veritable Civil War almost
every cultural and social institutions
in social institution has not just been
politicized but also weaponized now
again I don't know what that means that
that these things have been
quote-unquote weaponized they have been
politicized but weaponized is a bit of
an extreme term that Sports has been
weaponized it has been politicized it
has not been weaponized in the sense
that you're now banned from
participating in sports if you happen to
be a conservative or herb and if you
happen to be somebody on the Left but
Victor Davis Hanson continues Donald
Trump's election was not so much a
catalyst for the divide as a
manifestation and amplification of the
existing schism agree with that but he
says we are now nearing a point
comparable to 1860 and perhaps past 1968
left-right factionalism is increasingly
fuelled by geography always histories
force multiplier of civil strife red and
blue states ensure that locale magnifies
differences that were mostly manageable
during the administration's of Ford
Carter Reagan the bushes and Clinton so
he says that the country is polarizing
along Geographic lines
he says the globalization has undermined
national unity because we have these
iconic billionaires in high-tech and
finance and coastal elites but it's
hollowed out the muscular jobs largely
in the American interior this is just
not true
technology has largely muscled out a lot
of those jobs the manufacturing capacity
of the United States has actually risen
over the past three decades it's just
the technology has gotten a lot better
because as a country we have moved more
in the direction of technology doing
work that human hands used to do that
doesn't mean that we can't solve that
with job retraining and with programs
designed to get people into new
industries but the idea that
globalization is what is driving all of
this this angst I think is is not
correct
he says high tech has driven a lot of
this the mass production of cheap
consumer goods this is driving the
second civil war campuses are driving
the second civil war you know as
somebody who has been you know literally
banned from campuses campuses are a
terrible place very often but I've
spoken on probably fifty campuses in the
last couple years and 45 of them were
mostly ok the illegal immigration
he says the Obama project like I agree
with all of his critiques of where the
United States is going wrong so I think
it's all leading to a second civil war I
really don't now I want to explain what
could lead to a second civil war ok now
what actually could lead to a second
civil war I don't think is any of these
outside forces I don't think that it's
globalization I don't think it's illegal
immigration I don't even think that it
was the terrible Obama presidency which
I think really did exacerbate a lot of
the gaps in the United States
I don't think economics is what's going
to lead to a second civil war Victor
Davis Hanson a National Review he says a
steady three to four percent growth in
annual GDP would trim a lot of cultural
rhetoric 4 percent unemployment will
make more Americans valuable and give
them advantages with employers measured
meritocratic diverse legal immigration
would help to restore the melt in the
melting pot performing the university
would help to mostly by abolishing
tenure requiring an exit competence exam
for BA degrees and then he gets to the
one thing that I think is correct okay
here is the one thing that I think
Victor Davis Hanson says that is correct
he's ignored it through most of the
article but this is where I think that
he is right he says religious and
spiritual reawakening is crucial the
Masters of the Universe of Silicon
Valley did not as promised bring us New
Age tranquility but rather only greater
speed and intensity to do what we always
do trolling docks and fishing were just
new versions of what jesus warned about
in the Sermon on the Mount spiritual
transcendence is the timeless water of
life technology is simply the delivery
pump we confuse the two this I totally
agree with ok this is the part where he
is totally right one of the things that
has happened is that we have polarized
along technological lines because it is
easy to sit behind your keyboard on
Twitter and say mean things to other
people you would never say to them in
person it's easy when you don't go to
church to slander your neighbors as
people without teeth as mark
was doing it is very easy when you don't
actually have a community you feel a
sense of belonging to to talk about
going to war with all of your neighbors
all that stuff is a social isolation has
actually increased in a time of social
networking which is one of the great
ironies of the rise of Technology we
spend less time with human beings we
spend more time online pretending to be
with human beings and treating people
how we would not want to be treated did
we actually meet people in regular life
what's missing is the spiritual
component this sense that we're all in
the fight together and that's been
missing for a while in the United States
that's nothing new the problem is that
all of the civil war talk actually
exacerbates the problem this is the
problem I have with the civil war talk
the civil war talk and you want to talk
about a crisis of American conscience
I'm with you if you want to talk about a
crisis of American spirituality I'm
totally with you if you want to talk
about a crisis in the West of meaning
and purpose not only am i with you I
wrote an entire book on it or an entire
book on this crisis of meaning what
we've lost why we lost it I think that
we've lost a couple of things in the
West I think we've lost the idea of a
judeo-christian value system that bound
us all together and we also lost the
idea of reason as a universal solvent
that was going to help bring us together
and also grants us the capacity to talk
with one another and we've broken down
into identity politics and subjectivism
I think there are a lot of things that
have gone wrong with our culture but
talking about civil war only exacerbates
the problem because the problem was
saying that we're on the verge of a
second Civil War is that it actually
encourages you to look at people across
the aisle from you and not see the
common face of an American but see
somebody who is your enemy attempting to
destroy the United States and what and
that's not to say that that conflicts
between left and right don't exist they
do and I think the left is dead wrong on
virtually all of these issues I think
fighting leftist principles is a deeply
important thing because I think the left
is complicit in the destruction of these
central ideals of America that bind us
together I think the left has forcibly
attempted to destroy the judeo-christian
fabric I think that the left has
abandoned reason on behalf of of
subjective feeling but I also think that
most people in the United States are not
quote unquote
on the left and most people in the
United States simply are told certain
things by the media and they believe
those things because members of the
media say them I think a lot of people
in the United States don't even think
about policy very often they don't think
about politics very often and if they do
think about
I think they are driven into a state of
insanity by all of the talk of this sort
of civil war mentality the war is on
America's on the verge of destruction
the greatest freest country in the
history of the world most prosperous
country in the history of the world were
on the verge of chaos that sort of talk
I think makes things worse I don't think
we're on the verge of chaos but I think
that we have to look at the underlying
trends and try to reverse them I think
that would be the best way to talk about
this we're not on the verge of the
collapse of the United States we're not
and Donald Trump is not a symptom of
that nor is he a cause of that we are
not on the verge of the collapse of the
United States 500 disgusting idiots
marching in charlottesville is not the
collapse of the United States right even
even the shooting of Congress people by
an evil Bernie Sanders supporter that is
not the collapse of the United States
and the United States is a lot more
durable than that because it was built
on these principles what is the collapse
of the United States is when we forget
about this common fabric I still believe
most Americans believe in a certain set
of decency brought about by
judeo-christian values even if people
don't go to church I think they believe
in those values they just don't know
where they came from which means it's
our job to reinstall those values it's
our job to talk about those values let's
talk about where they came from why they
are important why people should go to
church why people should go to synagogue
at the same time we have to talk about
why it is that reason is necessary why
it is that classical liberalism the idea
that we are free because we have certain
inalienable rights why our reason allows
us to have a republic where we can sit
and talk together why that stuff is
actually important right arguments over
the tax rates are not going to destroy
the United States abandonment of reason
and abandonment of values are going to
destroy the United States and the
problem is once you get into a mentality
that we are in a war wartime mentality
encourages people to abandon morality
people are at their worst in a war and
one of the weird things about the way
that we perceive war in the modern world
because so few of us had actually been
in the military only a small percentage
of Americans actually even know people
who have been in the military or deal
with people in the military on a regular
basis because of that we tend to think
that war makes the best of people when
you watch war movies we see I'll look at
the unity of the guys in band of
brothers look how they came together
look how in a war there's a common sense
of purpose this is why so many folks
particularly on the political left like
to talk about the war on poverty people
on the right about the war on the
illegal immigration the war on Christmas
we're constantly using the language of
war but
we think that war brings us together and
refines us that pressure turns us into a
pure version of ourselves the worst
atrocities in the history of man kind of
happened during lore the reason for that
is because once you believe that you are
fighting in a battle once you believe
that your life is at stake
once you believe that war is at your
front door you are willing to do almost
anything in order to prevent yourself
from losing that war once you believe
that the country is one step away from
its end it's pretty easy to justify
doing virtually anything and I think
that that's having a pretty significant
impact is sort of civil war rhetoric on
how people think on both the left and on
the right so let's take an example over
the last 24 hours
several members of the Trump
administration have talked about Russian
meddling in elections and they talked
about how bad it is so Mike Pence the
vice president he says the Russian
meddling is offensive to democracy of
course he's exactly right the fact is
Russia meddled in our 2016 elections
Russia's goal was to sow discord and
division and a week in the American
people's faith in our democracy and
while no actual votes were changed any
attempt to interfere in our elections is
an affront to our democracy and it will
not be allowed okay so that's right what
my pen says there is exactly right and
then Christian Nielsen's the Homeland
Security Secretary she comes out and she
says election meddling is happening in
real time
Americans need to be aware of the very
real threat it's happening real-time FBI
has lead on that they have a task force
we support them and we work with the
private sector such as Facebook
companies like Facebook to try to pull
down content than is in a fennec okay so
there is a real problem with the
Russians meddling in our election now if
you're a patriotic American who believes
that Western civilization actually
requires defense you should be offended
by the idea of a country like Russia
attempting to meddle in our elections
the idea that Vladimir Putin who's a
thug dictator who murders dissidents
interfering in our elections should be
offensive to you no matter where you
stand on the political aisle I was
deeply offended when Barack Obama said
to Dmitry Medvedev in 2012 that he
wanted flexibility from the Russian
government so that he could add that if
they were kind to him and didn't do
anything he would prevent he would
provide them flexibility in his next
administration I was disgusting Russian
interference in the election is a bad
thing but there's a new poll out today
and this is I think an out
of the Civil War mentality there's a new
poll out today and here was the question
in the poll if Russia were to help the
Republicans or Democrats keep or win
controlled Congress in the November
elections do you think their actions
would be appropriate inappropriate but
not a big deal or inappropriate it's a
big deal so according to Republicans
people who lean Republican fully 40% 40%
of Republicans say it would either be
appropriate for the Russians to
interfere our elections to help
Republicans win or that it wouldn't be
appropriate but it wouldn't be all that
big a deal if the Russians interfere in
our elections to help us win 40% of
Republicans say that it's not that big a
deal if the Russians actually interfered
in our elections and we knew that they
were interfering in our elections 4 and
10 55% say it's not appropriate it would
be a big deal which means that's the
correct 55% Democrats now say 14% say
that it would be inappropriate but not a
big deal 86% say it would not be
appropriate and it would be a big deal
ok so that is a you know that is a
massive gap that's a massive gap now I'm
gonna talk in a little while in a second
about why I think that those statistics
are what those statistics are I don't
think that this is about Republicans are
bad people and Democrats are good people
or anything stupid like that I think
that there is there are a couple of
explanations for this but you'll have to
explain on the other side of the of the
Facebook so go over to Daly wire.com
right now and subscribe $9.99 a month
gets you the rest of this show live
against the rest of Michael Moses show
live Andrew Clavin show live you get all
of those goodies and we have extra
goodies that come out behind the paywall
on a fairly regular basis go check those
after $9.99 a month and you can get for
$99 a year this the very greatest in all
beverage vessels the $99 a year annual
subscription leftist here's hot or a
cold tumbler go check that out right now
also subscribe to our YouTube or our
iTunes and when you subscribe to youtube
please hit that bell so you get all the
notifications we do have a brand new
Sunday special coming out this Sunday as
we do every Sunday this time with David
Mamet one of the probably America's
greatest living playwright he stopped by
and we chatted about art we chatted
about politics and we chatted about his
new book Chicago it'll be great hi my
name is David Mamet please tune in a ben
shapiro sunday special we're going to
talk about the truth behind the rumor
that the john f kennedy was killed by a
drunk driver so go check that out that
will be up on sunday it'll be a blast we
are
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
so there are two factors that are
leading to this disparate polling right
so what the polling shows again is that
40% of Republicans think that if the
Russians interfered in the elections to
help Republicans maintain control of
Congress in 2018 it wouldn't be a big
deal 14 percent of Democrats say that if
the Democrats were helped by their by
the Russians it would be a big deal okay
so why 40 versus 14 there are two
reasons
okay reason number one is the most
obvious reason which is that the
Republicans who are answering this poll
are seeing are actually not answering
the poll question this is one of the big
problems with polling of Republicans
right now any time a pollster mentions
the word Russia Republicans immediately
trigger and they immediately go to I'm
going to deny that anything bad has ever
happened with Russia because you guys
are making such a big deal out of this
Russian nonsense you keep saying that
from the election was a legitimate you
keep trying to make this into Trump as a
tool of the Russians well f you right so
this answer is basically f you to them
to the media and the pollster who are
asking questions I think that really is
what's driving this because honestly I
felt this feeling to say I went to a
place called the Magic Castle up here in
the hills and how it's a great place
it's really fun there's a magician who
actually has I think that's shown on
Netflix coming out soon very terrific
magician but at the very beginning he
made some joke about Trump and I was so
tempted to stand up and just start
yelling at the guy because it's so
irritating it's all really really
irritating so I think that part of that
statistic that 40% of Republicans don't
care if the Russians interfere in the
2018 elections I think that that
statistic is largely driven by
Republicans going you know what screw
you I'm not answering your question
because you keep making a big deal out
of this Russia stuff part of it is that
a lot of Republicans really believe that
if we are in the midst of a civil war
any and all means necessary to defeat
the opponent are on the table this is
the danger of talking civil war and I
think Democrats felt the same way when
they felt that Barack Obama was
endangered they felt that anything that
helped defeat Barack Obama was it was a
great evil that had to be fought at
every possible turn so riots in Ferguson
well that was just a way of expressing
discontent with the system riots in
Baltimore just a way of expressing
discontent with the system well an Tifa
maybe they're a little bit extreme but
are they that extreme right this sort of
attitude
now pervades the country the belief that
civil war is upon us is almost a
self-fulfilling
prophecy once you start saying that
civil war is this far away people start
building up for war people start growing
their loins getting ready for battle and
that means treating other people around
them in more immoral fashion not more
moral fashion so I think that that's
that's why I object to some of the civil
war rhetoric and I think that it's
actually quite dangerous for the future
of the country for us to keep talking
like this instead of focusing on the
fact that we do have this amazing
edifice that we've built together and
that with the grace of God has been
built for us by people who came before
us what do we have to do to uphold that
edifice as opposed to tearing it down
and yes let's have the fights with the
Socialists let yes let's let's talk
about the foundational principles of the
United States but let's not pretend that
we're on the verge of shooting each
other in the streets because we actually
are not I also think that the more the
Republicans talk like this the more
they're going to off-put the independent
vote I think the people in the middle
don't want to hear this most people
don't want to be bothered is the truth
most people want to be left alone and
people constantly shrieking in your ear
that the civil war is coming is not
actually of benefit to you electoral II
by the way when the civil war does come
you know if the civil war were to come
in I think several decades I don't think
that it would come from tyrannical
Republicans cramming down their values I
think it would come more from tyrannical
Democrats outlawing hate speech
outlawing religious practice attempting
to crack down on my church my synagogue
attempting to take my child away from me
if I don't teach them their preferred
social policies right that's where
things are really gonna get bad but I
think it's gonna be a long while before
we get there because I still think that
the vast majority of Americans don't
believe like the radical left believes
that said this is one of the reasons why
it's important how we talk about
politics this is why the mannerisms of
militants actually don't help us
generate victory they don't help
generate political victory what helps us
generate political victory is making
better arguments than the other side
calling them out when they make bad
character attacks calling them out for
lack of character when they do those
sorts of things but the constant the
constant idea that we have to hit be
weapons up all the time eventually
somebody's gonna pull the trigger and
things will get ugly at that point the
more weapons that go up the better
chance that somebody is going to pull
the trigger and that is a serious
problem
now speaking of pulling the trigger
there is a crazy thing that is happening
right now where a bunch of folks on the
Left are now attempting to ban 3d gun
printing we talked a little bit
yesterday about the fact that folks in
the media do not know what in the hell
they are talking about
when they talk about printing of 3d guns
they really think that I'm going to take
my HP LaserJet and print out a gun in my
house right now like they they really
think that's the thing I can do that I
can just go into my library and I can
print out a gun from my from my normal
printer because they hear printing and
this is what they think that's not how
it works an actual 3d printing machine
costs upwards of eight thousand dollars
all the way up to a hundred thousand
dollars nobody is sitting in their
basement actually printing out fully
plastic guns and that is illegal you are
not allowed to manufacture guns that are
not detectable and that is just not
something that happens people have been
manufacturing their own guns literally
for centuries people making guns in
their house with gun making kits most of
those who made of metal most of the
parts are coming from actual gun
manufacturers but the left is driving
this narrative that the new great danger
in the United States is going to be 3d
guns that's going to be the great danger
that's where all of the danger in the
United States is coming from so senator
Markey who doesn't know legitimately a
damn thing about guns he was speaking
yesterday he says 3d guns are a national
security risk in a world where a 3d
printer cartridge has become as deadly
as a gun cartridge and that's because
these downloadable firearms are
available even to those who could not
pass a background check
it's the ultimate gun loophole what in
the world is he talking about Ed Markey
does not know what he is talking about
the idea they're a bunch of felons who
are sending their basements with
$100,000 printing machines for 3d
plastic guns is just ridiculous if a
felon lawns to get a gun the easiest way
to do it is just to buy it illegally
really it's gonna cost you like a
thousand bucks as opposed to I don't
know a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars to manufacture a 3d ar-15 that
fires three times before it breaks the
hole this is so stupid but a federal
judge has now blocked 3d gun plans so
according to CNN if you are looking to
download the blueprints for how to make
a plastic gun using a 3d printer you
can't yet get them online from a site
distributing them legally a federal
judge Tuesday night locked a settlement
that would have allowed defense
distributed a texas-based gun rights
organization to legally post blueprints
for 3d principle guns but hundreds of
designs reportedly were downloaded
before the judge's decision meaning
those designs are out there legally or
not well yes I mean the idea that you're
going to shut down every site on the
internet that is posting these
prince is just asinine and a significant
violation of free speech the idea that
your first of all you can buy the
Anarchist Cookbook right now at Barnes &
Noble you can go to amazon.com and you
can buy the Anarchist Cookbook which
actually includes bomb-making lessons
okay so the distribution of information
is not what's going is not the serious
problem here the distribution of
information is not what is going to lead
to the collapse of the United States I'm
much more fearful of the federal
government stepping in and saying we are
afraid that you're going to manufacture
a gun in your own house therefore we are
going to regulate what kinds of sites
are on the Internet by the way everybody
just went to an alternate site yesterday
they shut down one site and everybody
just went to an alternative site but
this is my great fear this if their if
journey is gonna come in the United
States it's going to come from people
who are so fearful of the liberty of
Americans that they believe that the
government should shut down all sorts of
freedoms that we hold dear right that's
where tyranny is actually going to come
from it's not going to come from the
idea that globalization and additional
technology is exacerbating cultural
differentiation which leads to us
picking up guns and going and invading
the local Starbucks that's and that's
not a thing that's that's really in the
offing and so again media ignorance on
full display they're just doing a
wonderful job meanwhile the President of
the United States is sounding off again
about Attorney General Jeff Sessions he
tweeted out earlier today that there's a
terrible situation surrounding the
Moller investigation
he says Attorney General Jeff Sessions
should stop this rigged witch-hunt right
now before a continued sustained our
country any further Bob Miller is
totally conflicted his seventeen angry
Democrats are doing his dirty work and
are a disgrace to the United States
again Rudy Giuliani call your office
tell the president not to tweet things
just as a lawyer this is not good okay
they are now investigating president
from for obstruction obstruction as the
implement is the impediment presenting
impediments to the Muller investigation
and he's fully tweeting out he wants
Attorney General Jeff Sessions to fire
this guy it's just it's none of it as
smart none of it is smart and again the
the creation of a crisis mentality
around issues where there really is no
crisis I think is a major mistake in
virtually every way okay time for some
things I hate things I like and then
some things I hate and then we'll do a
long-awaited Federalist paper because we
miss doing it a little bit earlier this
week okay so things I likes I've been in
the middle of this delightful book I'm
called Jonathan strange and Mr Norrell
by Susanna Clarke and it's sort of is
Harry Potter for grown-ups
it's Emmett
Dickens which means that is rye and it's
humorous and it's also kind of creepy so
basically it's English magic comes back
at the beginning of the 19th century via
these two guys Jonathan strange is kind
of a likable but quirky doof and Mr
Norrell who is a nebbish and and the two
of them are supposed to restore English
magic it's it's really entertaining it's
super long and say that so I will admit
that the reason that I picked up this
book is because dana perino and i were
talking we decided to start our own
private book club and so both of us are
reading this I don't know how far dana
is into this book I will have to ask her
later but I am enjoying it too go check
it out there's also a BBC series they
made out of it that got really good
reviews which is next time I watch list
as soon as I finish this book other
things that I like so I have to admit
this Ron DeSantis had is so funny so Ron
de santis who I'm friendly with
congressperson from Florida he is now
running for governor of Florida I
believe that DeSantis should win I think
he's a good candidate and I think that
he will make an excellent governor of
the state of Florida really smart guy
his family is very charming he cut this
video he cut this this ad in an attempt
to win the primaries in Florida and
obviously he has to show allegiance to
President Trump in order to win the
primaries in Florida so he goes over the
top and it's really really funny
everyone knows my husband Ron De Santis
is endorsed by President Trump but he's
also an amazing dad Ron loves playing
with the kids build the wall he reads
stories then mr. Trump said you're fired
I love that part he's teaching Madison
to talk make America great again
people say Ron's all Trump but he is so
much more
big-league so good
you should know so I love the the kind
of tongue-in-cheek of it and it is true
obviously DeSantis has been a trump
supporter and he is a he will be he will
be an excellent governor Trump himself
has endorsed DeSantis which will help
just answers in the primaries I think
you're looking at the next governor of
Florida in Ron's DeSantis which is just
terrific okay some time for some things
that I hate so when I suggest that the
extreme rhetoric come left and right is
bad for the country I mean it DL Hughley
who has been featured on CNN remember
these are the same people who suggest
that the media are truth tellers and are
attempting to bring the country together
DL Hughley who's allegedly a comedian he
was talking about dak Prescott dak
Prescott is the quarterback of the
Dallas Cowboys and he said he's not
kneeling for the national anthem because
he thinks it's stupid Anil for the
national anthem which is eminently
correct so deal Healy suggested of
course that the dak Prescott is not
actually a black person you want to make
it money you could save nothing but you
chose to speak for the master you chose
to speak for the message and I say this
and I say it's perfect there to players
who would speak up for the cowboy owners
at least you got the boy part right this
kind of stuff is really amazing so I've
been criticized in the past for
suggesting the Jews who vote for
abortion policy for example or same-sex
marriage that they're Jews in name only
because Judaism is actually a creed that
has certain values attached to it and if
you ignore those values then you may be
ethnically Jewish but you're actually
not participating in the religion of
Judaism in any serious way being black
is not actually a Creed being black is a
color you can't change it right you are
what you are and so when DL Hughley
suggests that dak Prescott is no longer
a black person he's a boy working for
the master because he doesn't want to
kneel for the national anthem and says
that it is bad to kneel for the national
anthem that's sort of bigotry on a
national stage is completely ignored and
that is bad for the country that is just
another example of extreme rhetoric that
the left will ignore while they're
jabbering about how people are being
mean to Jim Acosta at a rally and again
I don't think it's great to be mean to
Jim Acosta at a rally I think you are
serving Jim Acosta's purpose of
worshiping Jim Acosta when you do that
but I also think that the left has
ignored extremely al Sharpton still has
a show on MSNBC for God's sake the man
was was responsible at least in part for
or an instrumental in helping to incite
a race riot
in Crown Heights in 1991 that end with
the murder of an Orthodox Jew so I mean
and that guys are shown on MSNBC it's
really kind of sickening speaking of
extreme rhetoric you know when I talk
about the civil war rhetoric that's
emanating from from every side right now
Andrea Mitchell who's supposed to be a
reporter last time I checked right she
was on Comedy Central and she compared
President Trump to Stalin which makes
perfect sense because they're exactly
the same except for not the same in any
way that you can actually measure
there's Andrew Mitchell making that
comparison I do think that he has very
deliberately set up the press as the
enemy of the people I don't feel that I
am the enemy of the people and it's it's
not benign I mean just
[Applause]
something that we first heard from
Joseph Stalin this is very dangerous it
undercuts democracy okay the difference
is that if Joseph Stalin thought you're
an enemy of the people he would take you
out and shoot you right Donald Trump
says a lot of things but Donald Trump
has yet to shoot Andrea Mitchell thank
God you know this is the this is not do
I like Trump's rhetoric about the media
no I've been very critical of President
Trump's rhetoric about the media because
I don't think that everything he says is
fake news is actually fake news and I
don't think the press are the enemies of
the American people or anything like
that I think that are self-involved I
think there are self-indulgent all too
often I think they have their own
priorities but I don't think that they
are you know actively attempting to
destroy the American people or anything
like that
that said comparing Trump to Stalin is
not actually making it's not making
Trump's case harder that you're doing a
bad job as objective members of the
media that's for sure okay time for a
quick Federalist paper so every week we
go through Federalist paper we're all
the way up to Federalist 39 so we're
moving steadily through here so James
Madison wrote Federalist 39 and he is
making the case for why the government
of the United States ought to be a
Republican it's quite fascinating here's
what he says he describes why the u.s.
is a republic and not a democracy he
says that a republic is a government
which derives all its powers directly or
indirectly from the great body of the
people and is administered by persons
holding their offices during pleasure
for a limited period or during good
behavior it is essential to such a
government that it be derived from a
great body of society not from an
inconsiderable proportion or a favorite
class of it otherwise a handful of
tyrannical Mobil's exercising their
oppressions by a delegation of their
powers might aspire to the rank of
Republicans and claim for their
government the Honorable title of
Republic it is sufficient for such a
government that the persons
administering it be appointed either
directly or indirectly by the people
that they hold their appointments by
either the tenures just specified
otherwise every government in the United
States as well as every other popular
government that has been or can be well
organized for well executed would be
degraded from the Republican character
so recognize what are you saying that
what he's saying is what makes her a
republic is that we have a bunch of
elected officials elected by the great
majority of the public and that these
officials hold their offices during for
a limited period or during good behavior
this is a far cry from the bureaucratic
government that has been instituted
since the beginning of the 20th century
in the United States the legislature of
the United States has become the
withered arm of American government the
Constitution's article one presents
virtually all power in the form of a
legislature
there's no question that Congress was
meant to be of all the branches the most
powerful no question and yet it has
become in many ways the least powerful
branch of the American government which
demonstrates we have moved away from an
elected Republic more toward a
bureaucratic government that has created
all sorts of tension inside the American
system it's the reason why people feel
frustrated that government isn't doing
what they wanted to do because your
elected officials have kicked over all
responsibility to a bunch of unelected
life tenured bureaucrats over it a bunch
of executive agencies this is serious
problem Madison continues by talking
about how the nation was formed the
reason this is important is because it
actually led to some arguments about the
actual civil war so what he says is the
way that the nation was formed was the
ascent and ratification of the several
states derived from the supreme
authority in each state the authority of
the people themselves the act therefore
establishing the Constitution will be a
national when not a national but a
federal acts he says the states
basically made the United States because
the form of the formation of the
Constitution had to be up he had to be
upheld on a state-by-state basis
universally and then he describes the
Republic this way says the proposed
Constitution is in strictness neither a
national nor a Federal Constitution but
a composition of both and its foundation
it is federal not national and the
sources from which the ordinary powers
of the government are drawn it is partly
federal and partly national and in the
operation of these powers it is national
not federal meaning that it doesn't
operate on a state-by-state basis you
treat all the States the same according
to the Constitution of the United States
this is in the extents of them and is
again in federal not national meaning
that you can't override the rights of
the states and finally in the
authoritative mode of introducing
amendments it is neither wholly federal
nor wholly national now the reason that
this became an interesting battle is
leading up to the Civil War there was an
argument it was called state compact
theory that was made by members of the
Confederacy that basically if the
Constitution violated the original
prescriptions that were signed off on by
a variety of states that those states
had the right to withdraw from the
Constitution just as if I signed a
contract with you and you break the
contract I get to withdraw from the
contract they say the states were the
signatories to the Constitution and
therefore if you violate the rights of a
particular state that state has the
ability to withdraw the counter-argument
was we have an amendment process to the
Constitution if you don't like how the
government is acting all you have to do
is pass an amendment you can't you don't
have the votes for this amendment and so
how exactly are you going to fight that
this this argument I don't think is
legally insignificant I also think it
has ramifications for today with regard
to what is the exact purview of the
state I think that the state compact
area is not entirely wrong from a legal
perspective the problem was it was being
fought over the great evil of the 19th
century slavery and therefore the moral
imperative to destroy slavery was
stronger than the legal imperative to
maintain states rights and that had some
dramatic ramifications for the federal
government going forward although the
truth is the full destruction of state
power really didn't happen until the
middle of the 20th century with the rise
of the federal bureaucracy okay well we
will be back here tomorrow to break down
all the latest I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah alvera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018